hey guys it's justine and today we are
heading into a studio to witness
something really awesome so i'm sure
many of you guys have seen nightmare on
elm street well they are recreating a
scene from that film but shooting it on
an iphone they have one of the original
gaffers i'm going to be chatting with
roy wagner who was one of the original
gps on this film and he's dping this and
shooting it on an iphone so it's gonna
be really cool to see that perspective
of you were here on the original shoot
and now you're here
reshooting it on an iphone it's just
really incredible so let's head inside
and let's witness some movie magic
[Music]
okay so here's the setup armando can you
walk us through what the heck is
happening here
okay so first of all what is this gimbal
so this is the moza
aircross air tube okay so normally
gimbals remember how you kind of it has
like a little plate here and you load
them this way yeah you can side mount
this
which allows us to go as large as we
need so if you have like really big
cameras like it works really great we
out rigged this
on a condor blue cage which allows us to
you know rig up other accessories this
set up here so we have a small hd
monitor
and this is a also a transmitter so
that's why it has the antennas up
up above so the way this is getting the
video signal is through this little
dongle
so apple sells these little dongles and
can connect an hdmi cable yeah
we have this and now this is
transmitting to the video village so
essentially you guys are going to be
sitting here right if you're the
director you get something even cooler
what do i get
you get this the director gets this
monitor
has a receiver so this is receiving the
image from here this is a teradek
small hd combination so what i'll do
just really quickly i'll go around so
you can
take a look okay i'm directing now and
this is the filmic pro app
which i've been such a huge fan of first
but you know do you think
it would be really fun if we get you
and roy to do a little quick scene do
you want to do that
yes so let's go ahead and do that so
what you're going to do is you're going
to run down this little
hallway and you're going to bump into
this little doll obviously the doll's
not there because you're going to kind
of stop here
okay for a minute get your bearings and
then run off camera this way
so what you're going to do is you're
going to kind of run here and then
there's a pretend doll here you're going
to go like
this and then you're going to run this
way all right and then you're going to
go off camera this way
i shouldn't have wore heels what was i
thinking
i didn't know i'd be running for my life
today
okay rolling tell me guys this is bts
we're rolling
a little more yeah
[Music]
should i scream is there a scream are we
gonna we can you know add that in post
looks great
that's pretty cool that looks cool so
that was shot at 60. i was shot at 60
frames per second should i air drop this
first
or do this okay this is so great oh my
gosh
the best part about it is you can air
drop the video like i can have this on
my phone right now
i should probably step back a little bit
closer to the then she also did a fall
there yeah that was great
this is nuts this is so great cool one
[Music]
more
like what's going on with what's
happening settings look good
so far we're kind of testing out
different profiles so that's the neat
thing about the application is that you
can shoot in like natural dynamic flat
and log v2 however because this is a
newer iphone
filmic pro did mention that they're
still working on the log v2 profile
technically it's not like done by time
people watch this video it's probably
going to be already live
is this the beta version of the app no
so we're trying to get a beta version
to try the joel filming like this yeah
so we're trying and hopefully tomorrow
uh there will be somebody from filmic
pro here
that might give us the beta version of
it but yeah no so far it's good i think
uh we're pretty happy
you've been great as a stand-in that's
awesome
that's harsh oh well you know i mean
so we are here on set and i'm with roy
now you were the original dp
on nightmare on elm street and now
you're back here duping
it on an iphone like what is this like
for you
to have just bizarre i've always been
passionate about new technology yeah
i've been in the business for 50 years
shot 70 millimeter uh 35 millimeter
and uh digital i was shot the very first
digital
series i've heard of people shooting
with phones before but i never thought
that i would be shooting the phone
and my partner said why don't we do this
with an apple iphone and i just gotten
the new apple iphone and was blown away
by the quality of
uh the images and to the point where i
wasn't carrying my silk camera
yeah so i said that's that'll be a
challenge that'll be interesting
last night i watched the first half of
the movie on my iphone
which is so insane that like i watched
on the device that you guys are now
recreating the film
and it's interesting because you know
that the technology that you guys were
using i mean it was
such that manual thing and seeing what's
happening now like
what is that like for you to just see it
all be i guess it's easier but it's also
there's so many other different
challenges it's easier but you know i'm
trying to
exactly replicate where the shadow falls
yeah where exactly the light hit the
wall
and so it's not like doing it for the
first time because i can be
completely wrong and i'm right yes
that's the first time but this time
i have to exactly duplicate what we did
before
and beside that you know even when
shooting film uh we were shooting with
the slowest film
possible it was there was no high-speed
films then
so we had to we had to do what we're
doing now
the the phone can be shot at low light
levels but you always want to work at
the
at the most the highest light level you
can so you get a prettier picture yeah
let's go back to some of this original
stuff because this is the best thing
like you've
kept this well i keep it for everything
i've done
csi beauty and the beast here's the
original script
this is crazy what was like your
favorite memory from
who just you know created always about
people yeah
i i love the camaraderie of crew because
it's
it's like you know it's like the circus
yeah
and of course every every scene is drawn
out
and uh so that we know how how we're
going to do it this special effects
people
detail how the shots will be done and
uh of course letters of of how it has to
be
done a very particular way there's the
freddie snake oh my gosh
i mean like what else is in here this is
like an arsenal of
well if you wanted if you wanted to make
the movie again this was
you could look at this and you would
know how he did it i mean you could
technically if you wanted to you could
shoot this and edit it on an iphone
which is really that's exactly right and
what what's so exciting about that is
that that means that
all those aspiring filmmakers like we
all were
at one time can get their hands on a
camera
much more quickly for sure and can go
out and make their film
and not have to go through a studio
or through a committee of executives to
tell them no you can't do it this way
you have to do it that way which is
what's great about youtube i mean i
started
i mean a very long time ago like i was
editing on two vhs players
that my parents were thankfully nice
enough to let me just use
so i mean i've been editing for such a
long time as well just to even
see that change and just go from you
know film to tape to digital you get to
follow
your dreams i mean the thing is nothing
we call it the democratization of
filmmaking
but it's a democratization of all all
knowledge yeah
so i think for maybe like my audience a
lot of them are maybe aspiring
cinematographers or even like whatever
it is that they're doing a lot of them
it's a younger audience
so like what would you give to them like
one piece of advice to just help in
either cinematography or just life in
general don't let anybody steal your
dream especially yourself
because i find nobody can steal your
dream by you
it's very true and uh just
never give up there is no right way
to do anything i've
i always tell people you know my book of
enemies is all filled up you're going to
have to be my friend
just having a great attitude i'm 72
years old i
feel like i did when i was making this
movie that's really cool
and uh it's you know it's
it's a thrill to wake up every morning
and to know that you get to do what you
dreamed of doing all your life
this is insane this is just fun this is
so amazing thank you so much for sharing
your story and your time
thank you very much and doing this
project and sharing it with us and just
wow
this is amazing i'm i'm looking forward
to seeing your your uh piece on youtube
and
i hope you'll look at mine and uh
i can't wait thank you well uh hopefully
uh
we'll be able to encourage not just
young people but everybody to follow
their dream yeah it's never too late to
do something that you love which is
amazing so we're inspiring you guys to
go out
i'm inspiring myself i'm inspired i know
i need to go shoot a feature film on an
iphone exactly
exactly this is cool thank you so much
always thank you so much for watching
this behind the scenes and thanks so
much for chatting with us
if you guys want to see the full
recreation i'll put a link in the
description and you guys can go check it
out
so thank you again thank you this is
amazing oh and happy halloween
happy halloween